hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 7 video it was
titled penguins umbrella but Victor's
ass was like the big new character that
they introduced both he and the penguin
got amazing themes the ringtone ons
asses phone was Funkytown and the
penguin got this original score that
sounded something like a twist on the
Sherlock theme from the BBC Sherlock I'm
gonna think of it as like the Penguins
edition of the game is on theme there's
also some really cool news about new
Batman villains the show is gonna bring
on in the second half so I'll explain
that at the end of the video careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet but starting with top five moments
number five Gordon has a plan it might
not sound like a very good plan and
ultimately it really didn't go down the
way he expected but I do have to give
him a hat tip for having the balls to
march into Falcone's home with the
machine gun if you're confused about
what the actual plan was supposed to be
he was gonna arrest everyone associated
with the Arkham City development the
mayor Falcone Maroni eventually fish
Mooney pretty much all the high ranking
mobsters I wasn't quite sure if Bullock
was gonna go along with it when he
brought the hooker the night before
everything went down I kept expecting
something to go sideways I still feel
like Bullock is on Falcone's take if
there's a plan within the plan with the
penguin there's got to be something
going on with Bullock - number 4 Montoya
and Crispus apologize they didn't
completely address the fact that Montoya
tried to steamroll Gordon based on the
way they left things I think Gordon is
cool with them I don't think he's gonna
punch him in the face or anything he
even told Bruce that they would take
over his parents case if something
happened to him that was one of the
scenes I felt they could have gotten rid
of Bruce crying and hugging Gordon I
feel like they didn't need that although
it did give us the chance to see Alfred
in action he is a badass I'm waiting for
him to punch someone in the face I feel
like Sean Pertwee would be amazing in a
fight even if he's not a huge guy I just
feel like The Legend of Alfred should be
a thing I'm interested to see if they go
a question route with Montoya's
character since she becomes the question
in the comics but that's only after she
hits rock bottom and this is just season
1 so it's probably a long time before
anything like that happens
number 3 the Arkham City development is
good to go Falcone explained that
everything is poised to begin with the
Arkham City construction what it's going
to be is just a cash cow for the mob
they're just gonna own all that real
estate so all the businesses everything
the
goes there all the cash that comes
through they're gonna get a cut of that
that was what the bargaining was for
that waterfront real estate
whenever the penguin suggested they'd
offer up that waste dump to Falcone I
know a lot of you were wondering if
that's gonna be some sort of solomon
grundy teaser I think there is something
there I mean think about it
we're house built on an Indian burial
ground near a madhouse what could
possibly go wrong
they haven't introduced a whole lot of
people associated with our commute a lot
of Batman villains that they've already
confirmed they're bringing on like Hugo
Strange so I think we'll see them the
second half of the season I do think
we'll see a fully operational Arkham
Asylum before the end of season one
there'll be 20 episodes total so that's
a long ways off number two meet Victor
Zsasz if you guys didn't recognize him
his name in real life is Anthony
Kerrigan a couple of weeks ago he played
Kyle Nimbus on the flash that's the
mists character so it's just a funny
coincidence that he's leapfrogging from
DC character to DC character the Victor
Zsasz we're meeting is obviously a
prequel to the one we'd see when a fully
developed Batman surfaces he originated
in the comics in 1992 if you noticed he
was carving marks on his arm that's just
one of the trademarks of his character
he keeps tally for all the people that
he murders that's why wouldn't we seem
in the Batman comics he's covered in
marks on Gotham here since that's like
ten years away obviously he hasn't
killed as many people yet the way his
characters explained in the comics is
that he believes life is pointless and
that when he kills someone he's freeing
them from a meaningless existence he's
mostly known for killing young women but
he will kill anybody he does usually
show up in most of the big Batman
productions like the cartoons or the
video games so you'll probably see him
in Arkham Knight whenever that games
released next year
I thought the actor had an interesting
presence on screen he didn't get that
many scenes the police station was
really his big moment isn't it funny how
quickly the police cleared the room this
is a very different Gotham than the time
of Batman even the captain thought it
was crazy the cordon even came to work
that day and my number one moment the
penguin and Falcone's plan revealed
every one is just a chicken to Falcone
now he's got his eyes on Arkham City
that's all he cares about it seems like
all the stuff that's happening with the
penguin Gordon fish Mooney and everyone
else is just amusement for him the
speech he gave to Gordon about order and
chaos is very important it's almost like
he
giving the prequel for what happened
during the Chris Nolan Dark Knight
trilogy the mob and Falcone provide a
certain level of order in the chaos once
you get rid of them the crazies and the
masks crawl out of the woodwork I think
that's just what Falcone was talking
about like he knows that if he's not
around things will get really crazy he
is an evil dictator so we got to take
what he says with a grain of salt just
hold out another 10 years Batman I'll be
here he'll bring order here's a couple
things I'm looking forward to now that
we know Falco knows about pretty much
everything that's going on one he's
totally gonna slice the Russian up if
you notice he's getting careless in
Falcone's presence like he was grabbing
Muniz but clearly he's gonna die really
soon Jada pinkett-smith very big
character obviously she's gonna weasel
her way out somehow if they're not gonna
kill her off at least not till the end
of season 1 and even then anything's up
for grabs just expect her to talk really
really fast and say something really
convincing to keep herself alive going
back to Gordon if you remember Falcone
said that he had a relationship with
Gordon's father I'll be really
interested to see if he and Gordon kind
of developed something on the side
Gordon is the white knight of Gotham
right now so I don't think that he's
gonna be making any deals with any
Devils anytime soon but he is being
forced into relationships like this the
thing he has going on with the penguin
is the best example of that whenever he
said Gordon will see the light
eventually all I could think about was
Gordon with the bat-signal just flipping
it on so the big thing we need to start
focusing on is Arkham City I feel like
the show's gonna go to that place more
and more as we get closer to the end of
the season or even the mid-season finale
of all the places in Gotham City they
can tell stories on this show I feel
like Arkham is gonna be the most
exciting and most rewarding for us as
viewers let me know that what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what did you think of Victor Zsasz
overall I gave the episode a solid
b-plus totally loved Victor Zsasz as I
mentioned it felt like he did a good job
of owning the room without overdoing it
I kind of feel like Jada pinkett-smith
does that just a little bit like her
character is just a little over the top
like if you're trying to place all these
characters you know you have Tim
Burton's Batman movies you have the
classic 60s TV show I feel like she's in
the classic 60s TV show everyone else is
in the Tim Burton movies in terms of the
Arkham story I feel like obviously
that's the thing that shows building
towards if they're trying to hit that by
episode 10 I do feel like they're on
track
two-face is actually coming on the show
really soon so I'll be looking forward
to that I mean it's gonna be a very
young version of Harvey Dent and I do
not think he's gonna turn into two-face
in any of the episodes we'll just see
the coin flip that's all all the
versions they've done to the character
in the comics in the animated series in
the Christopher Nolan movies the coin
flip was always a big thing even before
he became two-face and speaking of
Batman villains here's the big news they
just announced they're going to be
bringing a scarecrow on the way they're
doing it is they're gonna introduce him
as a kid
like somewhere near Bruce's age applied
just a little bit older but he will
eventually take the mantle of Scarecrow
from his father they haven't cast anyone
for either the father or the Jonathan
crane character but we do know that the
father will be an enemy of Jim Gordon so
he'll be someone that Gordon is chasing
down depending on how old the actor is
that they cast for Jonathan crane I
think we might get to see him play with
the Scarecrow mask a little bit at least
a little bit of imagery lots of stuff to
look forward to but let me know if
there's any other Batman villains that
you guys really want to see who do you
think that they should bring on I know a
lot of people want Solomon Grundy to
come especially with all the toxic waste
dump stuff happening around Arkham so
next week is gonna be our Harvey Dent
episode it's actually called the mask
which you know obviously could mean a
number of things
black mask Batman mask so many masks and
Gotham be sure to subscribe to get my
video I'll post it right after the
episode airs in the meantime if you guys
haven't seen it yet you can click here
for my Gotham episode 6 video and you
can click here for my episode 5 video
thank you so much for watching so it's
all high five and I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you